[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
buenas esta charla va de aportar valor
aportar valor es un es un contenido
quizás un poco más amplio que talento
decide engloba el talento pero también
habla de dos temas también uno es pasión
es decir podemos tener podemos saber
hacer cosas muy bien pero también
tenemos que saber qué cosas los mueven
cuáles son las cosas que nos motivan y
por otra parte de algo importante y son
los propósitos es decir de tener
objetivos claros por eso me siento un
poco quizás el ponente infiltrado en
esta historia dado que estoy si por el
tema del talento pero de alguna forma
voy a intentar construir un constructo
quizás un poquito más amplio para ello
os voy a presentar a mis alumnos
mis alumnos son personas como tú como yo
que pasean por las ciudades a veces
cuando estoy por palmas barcelona o
madrid no estoy paseando por allá me
pregunto muchas veces de todas estas
personas se nos habrá pasado a lo mejor
algún velázquez alguna 'rosalía de
castro' es decir cuántas personas no
habremos identificado en el sistema
educativo no habremos sabido donde
aportaba un valor para construir luego
proyectos profesionales que tuvieran
sentido
yo me pongo de ejemplo cuando empecé a
estudiar
de pequeñito empecé en una escuela
italiana de barcelona en esa escuela
tuve la aprendiz de una suerte de tener
una profesora llamada maría russo
quien nos enseñó bajo el método
montessori un método que funcionaba es
decir yo soy un niño montessori es un
método que funciona muy bien en temas
por ejemplo nos enseñaban a ser críticos
desde pequeños a no creernos
absolutamente nada a ponerlo todo en
cuestión a comprobarlo por nosotros
mismos no se llaman también temas como
competencias transversales es decir que
puedes hacer sobre todo cómo trabajar en
equipo con otras personas temas que
ahora estoy viendo que la escuela
pública es empiezan a trabajar y con
cierta intensidad sobre todo en las
fases de primaria pero mi problema bueno
también después cuando pase a la escuela
pública española en secundaria ahí fue
cuando un precepto ver programas para
empezar empecé a ver que tenía cuatro
cinco siete ocho nueve hasta entonces no
había tenido nunca una nota y no
entendía cuál era la importancia de
tener esas notas para que hasta entonces
lo que había tenido era un papelito que
ponía al nivel madurativo del niño y
cuáles eran sus intereses y cuáles sean
sus pasiones y donde portaba y donde no
aportaba valor
pero todo eso desapareció
así que de golpe y porrazo me encontré
en un momento supongo que muchos de
vosotros si sois de edades parecidas a
la mía mis alumnos de pedagogía todavía
veo que vienen bajo este sistema se
encontrado que una decisión tan estúpida
como vamos a hacer el resto de la vida
puede depender de que te llegue un
papelito en un momento dado y te diga
por aquí las carreras
e insisto algo tan estúpido como que
haré el resto de la vida depende de que
alguien tenga un codazo en ese momento y
te pregunte qué vas a hacer y digas pues
económicas apoyo también
y así decidí ser psicólogo
estudiar psicología vamos a dejarlo de
eso
en la vida me fue dando muchos tumbos
salir acabe la carrera empecé a trabajar
luego se explicaron una cosilla más pero
hay un hecho fundamental en esta
historia para entrar en el tema de las
de la aportación de valor y fue en el
año 2009 en aquel entonces pasó a un
hecho fundamental a nivel profesional
y es que una agencia de desarrollo local
en barcelona me llamó y me dijo mira
césar tenemos un problema si os acordáis
el año 2009 crisis económica no sé si os
ubicase pasaron de 30 personas a pedir
información sobre emprendimiento a pasar
a 300 personas cada semana se acercaban
a la agencia de desarrollo preguntando
qué que se podía hacer para emprender no
porque fueran emprendedores sino porque
necesitaban trabajar
ante esa avalancha esos responsables se
dieron cuenta de que la oferta formativa
que tenían estaba pensada para gente que
ya era emprendedora pero no para los que
necesitaban ayuda en ese momento y me
plantearon si era capaz de hacer algún
tipo de formación cuyo objetivo fuese
poner el chip de emprendedor en las
personas para eso tuve que hacer un gran
trabajo de investigación sobre los
programas que habían en ese momento y me
di cuenta de un hecho fundamental y es
que para construir un proyecto
profesional viable la esencia se basaba
en construirlos sobre tres pilares
básicos primero ser capaz de que la
persona identificarse qué es lo que le
movía no cuando se ve cuando entraba en
la clase veía las 20 personas y lo
primero que le preguntaban es muy bien
qué es lo que quieres hacer difícil no
lo tenía claro no sabían qué es lo que
les movía pero tampoco sabían muy bien
oye dónde aportaban valor es decir donde
aportaban talentos cuáles eran sus
talentos principales tampoco los tenía
claro fueron personas como yo que venían
de un sistema educativo que no había
hecho énfasis nunca en identificar en
las personas donde aportan valor con lo
cual cuando acababan el sistema
estaban exactamente igual que en la
casilla de salida pero en este caso con
más problema porque con 45 años 50 años
recién despedido y necesitando trabajar
esto se convertía en un hecho
fundamental así fue que dije de alguna
forma de alguna forma tengo que buscar
apoyos ayuda para que alguien me
explique cómo es que no somos capaces de
identificar esto
y entrada en el departamento de
pedagogía aplicada me permitió acercarme
al modelo educativo finlandés no sé si
lo conocéis modelo educativo finlandés
es uno de los que en principio y según
el informe pisa pues tiene de los
mejores de los mejores resultados así
que les pregunté directamente a esos
profesores les dije oye cuál es el
secreto de nuestro éxito y me dijeron
pues vida no es un tema de horas de
hecho los niños españoles están 55 horas
de media los finlandeses 3
dije será una cuestión de dinero no
tampoco no es una cuestión de dinero me
dijeron los el importe que paga el
estado finlandés y el español por niño
a nivel y contextualizado
per cápita posible es bastante parecido
dije bueno pues dónde está el secreto y
me dijeron mirar nuestra teoría es esta
y es que
mientras vuestro sistema educativo se
basa en corregir los puntos débiles de
los niños es decir es un sistema
educativo que históricamente lo que ha
hecho es no me interesa quién seas tú
quiero que seas así bajo este modelo y
lo que el objetivo de nuestro sistema va
a ser que tallar te para convertirte en
este modelo
nuestro modelo es totalmente diferente
lo que hace es otra cosa de los 3 a los
8 años
nuestro objetivo es identificar primero
en los niños cuáles son sus pasiones
cuáles son sus talentos y cuáles son sus
creencias limitantes eso suena
y de los 9 a los 16 años el objetivo del
sistema educativo es acompañar a este
niño en el desarrollo de estas
habilidades de forma que un niño con 16
17 años en finlandia tiene clarísimo qué
es lo que quiere hacer
los nuestros y esto lo puedo decir por
experiencia propia sobre todo en la
universidad cuando les llega a cuarto de
grado que están a punto de acabar les
tiemblan los pies porque están en la
casilla de salida
se reengancharon por solar o un
doctorado o lo que haga falta para ver
si se inspiran luego se meten en un
trabajo sea el que sea y a ver si se
inspiran pero la gran mayoría de los que
estamos aquí seguramente muchos de los
que estamos aquí somos personas que lo
tenemos todavía muy claro y donde
aportamos valor ni cuáles son los
tratamientos ni cuáles son nuestras
pasiones así que dije bueno pues vamos a
las soluciones no algo tendremos que
hacer porque si os dejo con esto ahora
mismo
se habla
así que fruto de mi experiencia
profesional con emprendedores con 2000
emprendedores que pasaron por este
programa que se llama entrena para
entender del que hay muchas personas que
han pasado por aquí
que podía identificar
qué es lo que hicimos los influjos dando
cuenta de algunas cosas primero oye y si
las personas que tenemos las que somos
ahora de qué forma podemos ayudarlos a
nosotros mismos y ayudarnos sobre todo a
identificar en los niños pequeños este
tipo de cuestiones empecemos por pasión
como puedan identificar las personas
cuál es su pasión bueno pues nos dimos
cuenta de una cosa que para mí ha sido
reveladora me di cuenta de que las
personas y los emprendedores que
conseguían llevar los proyectos
empresariales más exitosos eran personas
que básicamente lo que hacían era seguir
jugando a aquello que jugaban cuando
eran pequeños
es muy fuerte
eres un niño que te gustaba jugar con
otros niños o jugar solo es crítico eso
te gustaba jugar al ego siempre que
jugabas al ego jugabas con los muñecos
de lego como si fueran playmobil y hacía
es una representación social o
construyas cosas
aquí te gustaba jugar
no es ninguna tontería la gran mayoría
de comerciales eran personas que les
gustaba relacionarse con otras personas
y ya de pequeñito se hacían cosas
parecidas
tienes a niños que de pequeños les gusta
ser arquitectos que les gusta construir
que les gusta destruir y volver a
construir a unos les gusta con
con instrucciones y a otros les gusta
hacer un juego libre pero es
absolutamente crítico de la expresión
ado aquí te gustaba jugar a ti segundo
punto talentos claro el problema cuál es
si yo haya pensado cuáles son mis
talentos pero no lo tengo claro y esto
me ha pasado
y qué hacemos porque claro el problema
lo seguimos teniendo aquí de qué forma
identificamos los talentos
bueno pues seguramente si has llegado a
esa conclusión de que has buscado mucho
no has encontrado quizás es que lo
tienes que buscar en ti porque lo
preguntas a la gente que te rodea quizás
lo tienen más claro que tú
porque una pregunta es a personas que te
quieran pero que te interese su opinión
cuidado a veces no coincide
en que soy bueno cuidado con muchas
madres en que soy bueno no malo
lo importante
quizás si ellos lo quieren más claro
y luego tu grupo de amigos
incluso lo podéis decir lo podéis hacer
viral
por whatsapp oye a esas personas que
consideran que son tu grupo de amigos y
por cierto si no tenéis grupo de amigos
no lo digáis que queda fatal vale os
inventáis un grupo vale pero pensando en
ese grupo de amigos oye seríamos capaces
de preguntarles cuál es cuando yo no
estoy en que me echáis a faltar porque
pensar una cosa con vuestro grupo de
amigos actuales de forma libre natural
nadie se ha presionado verdad cuál es tu
rol fundamental ahí tú eres la persona
que hace de chicle entre todos
eres el que medía entre los conflictos
en es el que organiza en es que el que
si no queda no quedan los demás
o eres el que le viene a llorar todos o
eres al que todo el mundo debiera pedir
un consejo fíjate que estás definiendo
cuál es tu papel esencial en un equipo y
cuáles son tus competencias y talentos
básicos
pero quizás insisto ya me lo he
preguntado muchas veces
si las respuestas no llegan quizás
tendremos que preguntar a otros a los
que nos rodean y una tercera importante
propósito
qué es propósito pasión y talentos y
esto es lo que me gusta y además lo hago
bien sí pero no tengo objetivos
y si el objetivo es lo vamos a ninguna
parte
me explico
objetivos
donde aprendí yo el tema del propósito
en el año 1995 y aparece un abuelo
pero si es cierto me tocó me tocó hacer
el servicio social sustitutorio sabéis
que en aquel entonces los hombres en
nuestro estado tenían que hacer el
servicio militar o sino declararse
objetores de conciencia yo había
estudiado psicología y me pareció una
cuestión un poco extraña e intentar
resolver conflictos mediante fusiles
cuando me había educado y me había
preparado precisamente para
solucionarlos mediante palabras pero me
parecía justo y me parecía interesante
que si el estado había invertido dinero
en mí y yo también lo devolviese de
alguna forma así que me fui a eslovenia
un campo de refugiados serbobosnios y
bosnio musulmanes
estuve durante seis meses con 24 años
trabajando fue mi primera experiencia y
fue donde realmente decidí que quería
ser psicólogo fue después de probarme yo
en esa situación
pero hubo un hecho fundamental más allá
de la situación complicada del campo
refugiados que para mí fue esencial y
fue un encuentro con una niña pequeña
mirada era una niña de 13 años que se
había quedado huérfana de padres
y cuidaba de sus tres hermanos pequeños
yo por las mañanas bajaba entonces
estudiaba el canto es cierto pero
y bajaba por abajo y me ponía a hacer
mis horarios no sé si habéis tenido
algún vecino músico ya sabéis de lo que
hablo el que toca piano la guitarra y el
que canta ópera en fin bueno yo bajaba
abajo al campo de refugiados y me ponía
ahí con las mujeres y con los niños
sobre todo pues a cantar ópera y de
alguna forma decía les voy a alegrar un
poco el día no
se va a hacer con día a mirsad a
y me dijo oye césar
[Música]
yo tengo gracias a dios
cada día por estar viva y por la suerte
que tengo de estar viva y poder cuidar
de mis hermanos
al lado tenía un voluntario que había
venido conmigo
que lloraba desconsolado porque la novia
no le escribía y tenía derecho también
pero en ese momento en ese momento me
planté
qué es lo que hace que ciertas personas
tengan estas actitudes delante de la
vida
en el caso de mi sala fue una bofetada
emocional y fue a hablarme de esto del
propósito de la importancia de tener
algo que realmente te mueva en momentos
complicados hemos pasado una crisis
económica yo tuve mi familia que me
ayudó un montón mi mujer y mi hija en
ese momento fueron mis anclajes
emocionales para tirar adelante
es importante tener ese propósito
identificarlo porque es lo que hace
también mover los proyectos así que voy
a acabar como lo dijo enrique octava sus
mujeres no se preocupen que esto durará
poco
solo con una imagen en este caso
que es de yo cuando tenía seis meses
creo que se convierte
y bueno lo pongo porque para mí es una
imagen icónica a nivel de red no es
decir
es ese niño que intenta saltar que
intenta salir de esa red no
y sobre todo porque quería dejaros sólo
con un par de ideas y es
por nosotros y por lo que viene creo que
es importante creo que estamos a tiempo
de ayudarnos a nosotros y sobre todo a
las próximas generaciones a identificar
dónde aportamos valor el mundo futuro
que llega es un mundo complicado pero
puede ser una oportunidad brutal si
sabes dónde aportar valor y puede ser un
problema brutal si no sabes dónde
aportas valor estamos a tiempo de hacer
estas reflexiones ya por nosotros pero
también por las próximas generaciones
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah